Lastly, an adjacency matrix can be used.
In computer science,
a matrix is essentially a 2D array, but
the lists inside are all
the same length.
A matrix can also be called
a rectangular array.
When you look at it,
it looks like a rectangle.
The adjacency matrix is actually
really similar to the adjacency list.
The indices in the outer array still
represent nodes with those IDs.
And the list inside still represents
which nodes are adjacent.
However, these inner lists represent
information in a slightly different way.
Before, the list contained just
the IDs of adjacent nodes.
Now the inner list has one slot for
every node in the array,
where node IDs map to array indices.
If there's an edge between these
two nodes, a 1 goes into the array.
If there's no edge, a 0 is present.
You might notice that the diagonal or
the place on every line where the row
number equals the column number,
is always 0.
This value would only be 1 if
there is an edge that started and
ended with the same node.
But we don't have any
of those in our graph.
You should also note that a single
edge shows up twice in the matrix.
For example, this edge shows
up when the row is 0, and
the column is 1, and also,
when the row is 1, and the column is 0.
Which method of representation you use
depends on what makes the most sense for
you and what operations you'll
be performing the most often.
If you're looking at node degree or
the number of edges connected to
a particular node, the adjacency
list will probably be the fastest.